and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and my name is
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 173 today
we're going to talk about digital
clutter we're gonna talk about
technological exhaustion we're gonna
talk about quitting social media we're
gonna talk about overall online health
and we're also gonna answer your
questions about digital minimalism with
today's guest our friend Cal Newport is
here he's the author of the new book
digital minimalism thanks for joining us
Kathy thanks so much man of course of
course happy to be here may you wrote I
mean we're gonna get into the book when
we answer these questions let me just
say you wrote an amazing book and I'm
really grateful for that because now I
we get all these questions of where
people ask us about technology and now I
can just pawn them all you have a
question about digital clutter here read
this book right yeah I totally agree so
the last time Cal was with us mm-hmm
we were in Washington DC well you were
well I was in Washington DC and no I was
there too but I was in a hotel room I
think a with a needle in my arm yeah
yeah
so Cal was there to fill in your spot
during our show yeah and I got to tell
you man he he makes a pretty good
judgment over his hair off a little bit
he stammered a lot just like me and it's
it's perfect well let's go ahead dive
into our first question here is from
Justin from patreon shout out to all our
patrons over on patreon I have recently
gone through Facebook and Instagram and
I'm followed people that don't bring any
benefit to me it was mainly old school
friends I haven't spoken to in years and
that I never see and I felt quite guilty
about it did you ever feel guilty about
going through your own social media and
removing people well I can tell you
right now Cal hasn't felt ever felt
guilty for unfollowing I was always
thinking cows advice would be just
delete your social media advice if you
don't sign up for it in the first place
so Cal you you were in this this
interesting space where
you are you're a young professor you're
of the generation where everyone around
you has at least dabbled in social media
but I think you you you never signed up
at all never signed up yeah
it's weird because I just wrote this
essay recently called techno tech coach
amber which is like the the sort of
technological echo chambers that we we
get stuck in and I I actually signed up
for social media
2010 my after my marriage ended my my
mom died I was just sort of looking to
connect with some new people that
weren't co-workers and like former high
school mates or something and so I I
signed up for Twitter Facebook and
MySpace all on the same day what a
hipster I'm still not in his top eight
you try and Ryan but anyway I signed up
in and I actually found a Minzy use
especially from Twitter yeah I don't
know if it has to do with my love of the
written word but in 2010-2011 I
connected with a bunch of people that
probably ultimately led me to your work
and then us connecting and becoming
friends and and I realized that in
connecting with people on social media
it was a really useful tool but it was
useful because I was using it in a
useful way so when I unfollow someone or
unsubscribe to answer Justin's question
here it's because I'm no longer getting
value from that thing but in a way we
feel obligated and used a lot of
research on this with different case
studies so what have you found when you
talk to people who were had this this
sort of social anxiety around social
media well I think there's two things
happening here so one there's this idea
that we need to have this constant
lightweight contact with weak ties in
our social network right so that's
probably the main thing you're losing
when you start unfollowing people or
unfriending people they're probably weak
ties in your social network the idea
that it's important to keep contact with
these sort of weak ties social
connections is something that was mainly
invented by the arrival of social media
it's something that has never really
played a large role in human sociality
and what about what about text messaging
though because that came along it became
popularized around the time of
social media yeah but but I find that I
do the same thing the weak ties with
text messages in a way now it is more
intimate because you have to share phone
numbers or write it's probably stronger
with text messaging you know the main
thing I hear on the road especially from
guys is that it's their high school
friends everyone has the the group text
message that they use when they're
watching like the sports game or
something like that it's kind of like an
email chain or something kind of like an
email chain yeah but that's often a
stronger connection I mean what was
social media really brought in was like
the old friend its roommate or the
person you knew you knew in high school
and in that instance there's really no
good evidence that having those type of
weak Chi connections is really important
the feeling is socially engaged but the
research and the research has been
evolving on this I mean I spent the
flight over here reading a collection of
new papers that all came out in the last
year where it's sort of a consensus
forming in the psychology literature on
social media and well-being and they're
really now trying to figure out the
nuanced models of when social media
makes you feel better and when it
doesn't and one of the few places where
it does make you feel better is when it
allows for you to develop intimacy with
a group that is not physically
co-located so like what you were doing
in 2010 is essentially the use case for
where social media makes you feel better
that you feel like I don't whatever I
don't fit in here there's a particular
you know whatever I'm looking for people
that I can't find locally but I can find
them on social media and through self
disclosure let's say form some type of
intimacy where you wouldn't otherwise be
able to talk to these people right I
think that that's the the most useful
case for social media for me well
there's two one is the connection side
the other is the broadcasting side sure
it and I think we've got some bleed we
haven't have some business questions
here but broadcasting also in a way and
see people use face the people who use
Facebook effectively whatever that means
they do use it as sort of a broadcast
method look at yeah instead of me having
to go around show everyone the picture
of my kid here now it's on on Facebook
now we can question what kind of value
you actually get from that that's why
fun really interesting that you talked
about in your book is how these social
interactions the more we have there's
actually studies that show the the
our mental health is the the lonelier we
are yeah well so this is what's going on
so if you look at these these more
recent papers which actually came out
after the book went the press so this is
really sort of cutting edge is the to
social media behaviors that seem to
clearly make people less happy is a when
you do what they call social snacking
which is using the easier lower friction
communication interaction online to
replace sort of in person or deeper
interaction it's just not a good
replacement so if you're broadcasting
the baby pictures instead of actually
having a phone call with your cousin
yeah and like hey here's what it's like
with the new kid you end up worse off
and then social comparison this is the
other thing we know is a major driver of
negative well-being and if you are doing
a lot of looking at people sort of
carefully curated photos I mean if
you're a parent you see everyone has
these photos of everyone's dressed in
white and it's their kids on the beach
and then the sun is shining or whatever
this makes people unhappy as well but
this is what most people are doing yeah
it makes people unhappy when they see
that you're saying because they're
Harrison makes makes negative well-being
because it looks a lot better what you
see what you see online people's
portrayals are called wait a second we
don't all wear white we're never taking
that picture you've never been to the
beach why are they on the bar they look
entirely on the beach so much right I
mean yes I think in a way what maybe
what we're doing there and I'm certainly
guilty of this in the past and I've been
a lot more cognizant of it recently
especially after reading your book but
but over the last several years doing
different experiments for me I think I
use social media at a point when it when
it sort of got out of control and it
it's you're rapaciousness sort of took
over my life I was be jealous of me
right now look how happy I am that was
the implicit message and I didn't even
know that I didn't know that on the
surface I it was like maybe this deep
down thing where all of a sudden it was
like hey look at how amazing my life is
look how you can even be a picture of a
you know toast piece of toast look at
this avocado toast you see look how
amazing my breakfast is or whatever and
and what does that make other people
want to do get that and then it breeds
that comparison thing yeah we had we had
Rachael Cruz on and her book is is love
your life not theirs
it's a whole book about the the problem
with with comparison we've been we've
been given this template and now we feel
like we're compelled to fulfill it and I
think that's where Justin is right now
and his question he says hey I've set
myself up I have all of these
relationships but ever weak ties most of
them are we talk but I would feel guilty
to just unfollow them is there practical
advice to do that well okay so a couple
things one what we know is the
foundation for a very happy social life
is actually making sacrifices and time
and effort for family close friends and
community right so you want to be doing
that if you're doing that you are going
to feel a sense of social connection
fulfillment which is going to take away
a lot of the stakes of now I'm
unfollowing
you know so and so that I've known from
a long time ago that kind of ties in
with like in your book you talk about
leisure and like how leisure is
important yeah and so doing these things
on a leisurely level are gonna be way
more meaningful than yes all these
relationships on social media fill in
the void that the tools are feeling for
you right now right so if you build a a
meaningful social life that's built off
a commitment and sacrifice to other
people I'm gonna come over to your house
it's a pain I'm giving up a couple hours
of my afternoon or what have to spend
time with you or help you clean out your
garage or something I am sacrificing for
you that is the the foundation of strong
social connections it doesn't take much
sacrifice to say hey Facebook told me
it's your birthday right and I clicked
happy birthday right that doesn't
actually build what we crave and so yeah
a lot of in the book with a lot of these
different tools that people are worried
about you right the first thing you're
doing is filling in the void that the
tools are doing in a lightweight way
then it's much easier yeah it's it's
interesting man after reading your book
I no longer I won't even tap back haha
or like oh you don't have an iPhone the
iPhone has his feature we're like you do
have one now so you can you hold down
and then like you can tap back haha or a
thumbs up or whatever yes when it shows
up as like a thought bubble yeah exactly
exactly so like I don't even do that I
don't like stuff on Twitter anymore I
don't like stuff on Instagram and it's
not because it's not because uh I'm
trying to like prove anything or show
anything but after looking at why I
actually do
that it is it's kind of a thoughtless
interaction it's it's you you give I'm
gonna do a bad job of paraphrasing this
we give the example of how you know we
we have to have these certain
interactions with people but to think
that we can supplement these meaningful
interactions going to a friend's house
helping them clean out the garage
supplementing that with a tap or with a
like or with a thumbs up I mean that is
it's kind of an insult almost in a way
well my wife is great about this right
so the baby picture example is a common
one right I can broadcast my baby
pictures then everyone can say you know
Congrats three exclamation points in the
Instagram comments but my wife's
instinct is always okay someone had a
baby I'm going over there and bringing
them a box that has XY and Z that I know
that they need right and that's worth
100x more yes like what yeah the
congrats three I mean I think it's kind
of implied right that people are excited
that and so that that type of thing goes
a lot farther right so you take away the
friction and this is why people end up
lonelier when they use social media more
in a lot of instances is because you
take away the friction you're convincing
yourself you're being very social she's
like I've been talking to people all day
long right I've been tapping the haha'
and the likes or whatever it is all day
long but for most of your brain which
evolved in a context where these glowing
screens and it exists it just thinks
you're lonely the even bigger problem
there is the Apes the form of
communication and connectivity when it
doesn't provide that the fundamental
connection that we need if it's however
if it's the first step toward that
fundamental connection then great but if
we just pretend that well I can just
outsource all of my connection to social
media I think that's when we get into a
problem do you know you hit the nail on
the head when you talked about how we
fear boredom like we are so scared to be
bored and it's so easy to get on social
media and to fill that void just a
little bit yeah but what we're doing
when we do that is we are programming
ourselves to fill the void with the
wrong thing and we just need more and
more and more yeah boredom is the reason
why we don't like boredom is that it is
it's a sensation that's supposed to
drive us into productive fulfilling
activities right and and so when you
replace the productive filling
activities with this which is just
optimized to give you sort of a quick
fix to get past the boredom you're
actually missing the activity that
boredom evolved in the first place
try to drive us to do like it drove us
to say get off the rock and get out of
the cave and go do some things right
build the spear pull your tribe together
whatever it was and so if you avoid the
actual things that boredom is supposed
to drive us to do like our grandfathers
you know you they would be out at the
Rotary Club or whatever carving the
canoe in the woods something like that
I mean boredom would drive you to do
that right yeah but it's meaningful and
we should we shouldn't be surprised that
when we take a really deep seeded
instincts things that have been evolved
into us over millennia and then we start
messing around with them with tools that
some 20 year olds with hooded
sweatshirts thought up in an incubator
somewhere we shouldn't be surprised it's
going to cause some problems yeah it's
just like when we began messing around
with food processing food to an
industrial food you know changing the
what we've been eating for thousands of
years like of course we had obesity
epidemics you're messing around with
something that our bodies that had to
head home yeah have been home the
process so this what's happening is this
it's like junk food yeah it's not that
it's evil but we've got to be a little
bit wary when we start messing around
with things like human sociality yeah
we've got to be more deliberate with it
I mean the whole book you talked about
the beginning how you started writing
this because you realize like the number
one things that's shaping our lives
right now are screens so we all the
screens that we have in our lives I'm
not saying that we need to get rid of
all screens but we certainly need to be
deliberate with the screens that we have
on our lives on what we are we are using
them Justin this is what I'll tell you
man you're true friends they don't care
if you follow him or not if Josh
unfollow me on Facebook
wait I'm gonna I even on Facebook if you
can follow me on Twitter or Instagram
Josh has never liked any of my pictures
I mean I don't I don't ever look at Josh
to be like you're a bad friend because
you don't give me those ephemeral
interactions but he accidentally follows
like my old Twitter that's awesome so
yeah there's a there's an at Joshua
Milburn that has just parked and it says
don't follow this account like it's all
I just don't want anyone to take my name
basically and so it says please follow
me at jfm on Twitter and Sean is like I
just follow this one later Justin here's
the thing man is if you are worried
about your friends liking you or not
your friends having meaningful
relationships with your friends then you
know instead of worrying about liking
their photos or following them on
Twitter if your friend has a kid yes go
over to their house and bring them
something they need create the
meaningful interactions with your
friends and you're going to have
meaningful relationships yeah yeah and I
think one experiment he might want to
try something I've done I did with
podcast recently because podcast has
become this new addiction for me too
that has supplanted my social media
that's because I don't have social media
on my phone but I have podcasts on my
phone because where else are you gonna
keep home right and so I unsubscribe
from every podcast that I that I
followed that I subscribed to and I as I
missed the podcast I went back and Reese
absque ribe to it and I've probably
unsubscribe from 90% of the podcast and
that can it can unravel it we have to
continue to be cognitive of about about
any of these well these things that
we're doing it's not a quick fix it's
not quit social media and then all of
your your problems are gonna be solved
it's not unsubscribe but I think maybe
that's a good a good space to start
start Ryan you did that you started from
zero with Instagram you unfollowed
everyone I just started on all the
platforms just to really think well I
took a month off just because I was I
was addicted and I was going you know
just scrolling through stuff so I'm like
if I don't have anything to scroll
through then I'm gonna have to be more
deliberate with what I'm looking up so
what I realized is I was getting some
value and I the reason out of the way I
found out who was giving me value is I
realized like oh these are the people
I'm actually going out and searching on
a regular basis to see what they're up
to or you know what's what's their quote
of the day or whatever it is yeah it's
it's a great idea I mean I think the
number one thing out of for Justin is
he's uncomfortable right now
he's uncomfortable because he's calling
calling down his social media following
or who's who he's following he is
experiencing a little bit of discomfort
get uncomfortable like if you're
uncomfortable it's because you're
probably a little bit bored and again
like we're all scared of boredom none of
us want to be bored so here's the thing
though is if you if you spend less time
on social media there has to be an
answer on what to replace that time with
so it's it's when you go back to talking
about living a leisurely life we
want to do leisurely things but you can
do much more meaningful leisurely things
like joining a cause or a sports you
know a recreational sports league or
something get uncomfortable and fill
this these bored these bored times fill
this discomfort Justin with activities
that are meaningful Justin I'm sending a
copy of Cal's book it's called digital
minimalism choosing a focused life in a
noisy world I think you'll find a lot of
value in that
shun can you also send him a copy of our
book essential it's 150 essays and in
there there's a technology chapter and I
go through some of the sort of stoical
experiments that that I walked my
ownself through just temporarily
depriving myself and Cal you did that in
your book as well were you and we'll
talk about that in a bit you temper you
have people temporarily deprive
themselves to see what is actually
adding value so I got rid of my phone
for two months I got rid of home
internet for a month that ended up being
five years in doing some of these sort
of experiments and technology helps you
figure out like oh wow I'm not actually
getting the value I thought I was
getting in and that's that's our in our
book essential so if you like our
podcast you'll like the audio book
version of that or if you want the book
book or the e-book we can do that as
well alright it looks like we have
several more surprise questions this
week about productivity about to-do
lists about calendars about using social
media for business about curating your
photographs digitally and I want to chat
with Cal about digital minimalism for
parents as well as the 16-person
actually wasn't 16 people was 900 people
yeah 1,600 person case study that he did
for his new book and if you want to hear
all that you can listen to this week's
maximal episode available exclusively on
patreon that's right you're currently
listening to our weekly minimal episode
but each week Ryan and I and low-cal
this week we record an entirely
different long-form maximal episode on
the minimalists private podcast which
gives us the private space we need to
discuss topics we don't usually discuss
in public plus patreon is the best way
for us to fund this podcast and keep it
100% advertisement free when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll receive a
personal link so that our Maxim
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you also get access to our entire
back catalog of more than 100 private
podcast episodes find all the details
and all the good stuff including an
additional long-form podcast episode
every week over at the minimalists comm
slash support i'll ryan what time is it
it is time for our lightning round where
we answer questions from social media
ironically we answer questions right
like a giant blanket of irony and Raft
Calum yes exactly welcome to our life by
the way
so for the last eight years everything
with everything I mean I'm walking down
the street and someone I'm not very many
wearing a long-sleeve t-shirt yeah it's
like okay yeah first time I heard that
buddy right I was at the grocery store
Mizzell and had like you know half a
dozen lemons or something it's like very
minimal and I do minimalist
[Laughter]
you talked about this in your book where
people look at minimalism they look at
minimalists like it is an extreme
lifestyle basically I get this a lot
yeah do you think this is in part
because of the art movement I think so
because well because if she's dark white
rooms and the two chairs I get that a
lot believe when I think of the stark
white room in the two chairs I'm
thinking I mean I'm an art history minor
I'm thinking this is like minimalist art
movement right but part of it is there's
some sort of appeal to anything that is
radical or extreme right it brings up
for me when minimalism goes extreme you
can actually see the the beauty within
the bones of the thing you go to the art
museum it's really well curated it's a
beautiful space but the reason it's
beautiful is because it is so well
curated and and we think well can we
apply that to our own lives as well is
it practical no no one lives in an art
museum but we can have the sort of
functional equivalent in our own lives
whether it's with technology or with
material possession I love how you make
the counterpoint of leg no no no
minimalism especially you know digital
minimalism it's not extreme what is
extreme is how we're currently using
technology how we're currently using
these platforms yeah well I mean
digital minimalist always notice this
right they do this transformation
they're much more intentional about how
they use tax do they use a lot less of
it and they look around and everyone all
the time is looking at the thing and
they're wondering well who's the unusual
one here like I mean if you if you come
from a time machine from 10 years ago
like what's going to catch your
attention yeah what's gonna yeah that's
what's going to catch your attention
that's what's unusual you're right yes
from the digital space the minimalists
are basically back to standard types of
behavior right I mean it's they're kind
of the normal ones yeah yeah in it's
weird like you and I were Ryan and I
helped propagate this problem because we
were in telecom for a long time right
and and we were we left in 2011 but by
then we had to sell that data man you
had they had to make sure that every
phone we sold walked out of the door
with some kind of internet usage on it
right right and so we helped propagate
the problem but now we're trying to you
know we've we've taken the red pill so
to speak yeah anyway our first lightning
round question around you wanna dive
into that yes a first letting round
question is from LC WC can you remain
relevant as a company or brand without a
constant media presence Cal you do it a
great example this because you have a
great brand you have a great following
you have a lot of readers I when I was
reading your book it was I broke my back
up back in January January 11th and I
had so much time to sit around and do
nothing read and watch Netflix so I was
tweeting out like oh I'm gonna read Cal
Newports digital minimalism that that's
next on the list and I'm like I can't
find a month quitter I think that's the
one I tweeted yeah well like that
they're like following no one right and
like it yeah okay so so asking about
relevance here we try to give like pithy
answers for this like we call the
minimal Maxim's and Shawn puts them in
the show notes but we can monitor on a
bit as well my pithy answer we can
unpack here is relevance is irrelevant
if we're not first contributing
something of value there's been this new
phenomenon of internet famous people
like who what are they go to influencers
yes oh my god yeah that's another pithy
answer I've never been influenced by an
influencer
jaison's ook say something like if you
call yourself an influencer you're
probably you probably don't influence as
many people as you think it's
interesting because I feel like I mean I
think Cal was influential yes
but that's that's the adjective not the
not the noun right and it's figuring out
like what the difference is like for me
ultimately he's influential because he
adds value through the work the
creativity the creations that you
produce so so I think about relevance
with respect to a business or a company
and that's one thing that comes up all
the time with people especially with
small businesses and I'm just thinking
how much is Facebook paying you to post
on on their their platform and what is
your real return on investment yeah I
mean I get this a lot I mean I usually
go back to that 2012 book I wrote about
career advice where the title is so so
good they can't ignore you right I mean
it's with Steve Martin's advice to
aspiring entertainers they wanted to
know like how do I get noticed how do I
get an agent he would just say be so
good they can't ignore you that works
like 90% of the time I mean if you want
to be the Kardashians you are incredibly
successful then yeah you probably need
to be really savvy with your social
media brand but 9 out of 10 times when I
talk to people who feel like just
generically speaking they need to be
active on social media they probably
don't now if they have a very specific
thing if you're advertising on social
media okay I get it it's like a miracle
box I mean that my publisher was showing
me what you can do there's a reason why
Facebook is worth 500 billion dollars
you can you can advertise the specific
people all right I'm not gonna fault you
for that but if it's just a Janeiro yeah
so there we go that's a that's with
respect to our values yeah so but I mean
so I get that like why companies use
advertising I guess right it's a
powerful advertising medium but I would
say nine times out of ten not ten out of
ten but nine times out of ten producing
something really valuable is what's
going to matter that's totally true
it's a beautiful tweetable answer Ryan
do you have a minimal maximum yes it's
very it's very much along the same lines
as what you guys are saying my pet the
answer is a company's relevance
increases in direct proportion to the
experience it creates so yes you'd be so
good that they can't ignore you
you're gonna be relevant if you're
creating an outstanding customer
experience yeah definitely yeah all
right our next question is from Donna
how can we keep up with work without
drowning in information well sounds like
an excuse Donna to use another Cal
Newport book I incorporated it into my
my pisser here deep work does not
intersect with breaking news and and for
me our breaking news is broken at this
point we've we've reached peak breaking
news it's always breaking news and it's
really become breaking entertainment not
breaking news it's a we it purports to
be reports to be news but it is I'm most
most news isn't newsworthy yes that may
be another pithy answer yeah Cal what do
you think about about this this
information firehose that we're facing
so I wrote this article recently for The
Chronicle higher education where it
opened on this emeritus computer science
professor at Stanford who's been writing
this sort of multi-volume treatise on
computer program he's been working up
since the 1960s but he asked this great
quote which is for some people I guess
their job is to be on top of things for
me I think my job is to be on the bottom
of things and this is a guy who hasn't
used email since 1992 because he wants
to focus on what's important yeah what a
hipster I by the way that's after having
used it for 20 years at that point
because he's a hardcore computer
scientist but I think that applies to
some more things we do than we think and
more things we do are probably better
served by us being on the bottom of
things
yeah the news be on the top of things
even the the journalists I talk to hate
the breaking news even the people whose
job it is to follow breaking news tell
me when the mics are off they get such
an incoherent picture of what's going on
when they're on Twitter that they're
actually better off waiting to see how
it comes together the next day in the
newspaper and so I agree the fire hose
the fire hose exists because it gives
you a reason to look at your phone you
look at your phone that helps use
companies get these multi billion dollar
valuations you know we didn't have this
ten years ago and I think we're all fine
so yeah absolutely it's it's funny man
after after reading digital minimalism
yeah there's a spot in there where you
talk about the cycle that we get caught
in you know you jump
new sights a new site to sports site and
dude I'm totally guilty of this it's
like I will go to one specific new site
and then I'll go to like you know one
extreme opinion to the next to the other
extreme opinion and I think I'm doing
something good for myself because I'm
like oh well I'm looking at both sides
and but - never have I ever went into
that you know whatever it takes 15
sometimes a half-hour if I get into you
know a couple good articles never if I
left my screen and thought oh thank God
I went and read that news yeah it's yeah
it's a it's hardly ever adding value
really when I look at it's more
entertaining than anything I love that
dude but not breaking news isn't it's
breaking entertainment that is it's so
true as most of the time yeah I mean
occasionally but here's the thing if
there's big enough breaking news it's
gonna make its way to me somehow without
me having to check Mother Jones or the
Drudge Report right yeah you're left and
right by the way yeah
Mother Jones yeah yeah it's like an
aggregator anyway it's the Drudge Report
for the left my pit the answer is this
step one if you were drowning in a
bathtub turn off the water
[Laughter]
turn down the information YouTube is is
is my Bermuda Triangle and I have to
avoid it because otherwise I will I will
fall down just this spiral of of
entertainment and it starts out as
information then all of a sudden I'm
watching Canadian Rap Battles six hours
later I'm not ruling on myself Ryan what
else you got for us this week
as always I want to encourage people to
read more and get informed and you can
do that by picking up Cal Newports
digital minimalism I highly encourage
you read it it's a it has totally
changed our outlook on social media the
way we use it the what we bring into our
lives and do during the patreon episode
like that was that was that was some
really interesting topics man about how
we we do are we adding to the noise or
are we doing something in tension are we
doing something good for our readers but
I so we just talked about that with Cal
and basically we were asking how should
we should we even use social media
anymore and he had a fascinating take on
it so you can check that out what else
you got Ryan I got some voicemail and
comments and tips from our listeners
check them out
I'm from Fresno California I just wanted
to leave a comment for listeners but I
tried to do minimalism I noticed that as
a woman I have so many products and as
far as makeup lotion perfume makeup
remover and just a lot of bathroom
products so I looked into more natural
ways to get more function out of product
and I went ahead and switched over to
using coconut oil which can be used to
or basically any products that I had I
was able to replace it with coconut oil
and I went ahead and just threw away a
bunch of the products I had and it
really minimized the amount of clutter I
had under my sink in my bathroom which
was really freeing so just wanted to
share that tip thanks hi my name is
Nakia and I am from Nebraska and
listening to the spouse's episode it
really got my mind wandering of some
guilt that I had been holding on to my
husband when we were dating I got rid of
some of his things such as a Packers
poster and I got rid of some golfing
things and some bowling things and we
don't live in a house where there's room
for a man cave or a she shed but I
really just decided that and with the
help of my spouse we talked about it and
we decided that we don't need a space in
our home
that is dedicated to things that we wish
we would be doing so we have pledged to
each other that instead of deciding that
we want to hang Brett Favre on our wall
work my husband is more than welcome to
go watch a Packers game or maybe someday
we'll get to go instead of having Phil
Mickelson up on our wall or having a
glove with his name on it we can just go
ahead and he didn't go golfing or
perhaps get to go to one of our one of
his things that he does in go so that's
just my suggestion just to just to go
and do this
verses surrounding yourself with the
things that you wish you would be doing
alright Joe that's it for this episode
well almost it thanks again to Cal
Newport for joining us today check out
his new book digital minimalism in his
blog at Cal Newport dot-com is
subscribed to his blog I think it's like
one of four blogs that I subscribe still
to go man yeah it's really good and real
quick for right here right now this week
here's what's going on in lives of the
minimalist we touched on this a little
bit during the patreon episode Ryan but
if you all get a chance you can check
out our screen --less Saturday's video
that Jordan recorded we talked a little
bit about the experiment we did he
recorded an all analog video so good
analog video analog audio on a Saturday
we went out to a park and it was it was
a really good experience you can check
that out on youtube.com slash the
minimalists if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast leave us a voicemail for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
or send a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalist if you want our show notes in
your inbox sign up for our email list at
the minimalists comm and you'll also
receive our simple Sunday emails each
week Ryan before we head on over to
patreon hear that patreon episode do you
have anything that's added value to your
life recently man I already talked about
a digital minimalism go get a copy right
I'm gonna play you out today with my
added value this week it is a song
called maybe you're the reason by a gal
she goes by the name the Japanese house
is her stage name and her new album is
called good at falling and this it's
like this upbeat sort of upbeat
singer-songwriter electronic it's it's
just the it's the perfect soundtrack to
a night time Drive so you all can check
that out at the end of this episode
alright y'all if you leave here today
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus